Let's think a
little bit about how
we can tell whether our body
is processing glucose properly,
and whether maybe
we have diabetes.
And I want you all
to take all of this
with a huge grain of salt,
because I am not a doctor.
This is not medical advice.
My goal here is to kind of just
explore the subject with you,
and to try for all
of us to get a better
understanding of things.
So let's think about what might
happen after we have a meal.
So let me draw a
little chart over here.
So let's call this hours.
And then on the
vertical axis, I'm
going to talk about our
concentration of sugar
in the blood.
So blood sugar concentration.
You could call it
glucose concentration.
Blood sugar concentration.
When we're talking
about blood sugar,
we're talking about glucose.
And let me draw a couple
of points on this chart.
So maybe this is 50.
And our units are going to
be milligrams per deciliter.
Actually, let me
just do it this way.
Let me just say that everything
is in milligrams per deciliter.
And we'll talk in
future videos about how
we can relate these
units to everyday terms.
But let's say that
this right here is 50.
This right here is 100.
This right here is 150.
And let's mark it
right here at 200.
So let's think about what would
happen for a normal person.
Let me mark some
hours over here.
So hour 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7, 8.
That's probably good enough.
So in a normal person, when
they haven't eaten anything
for a long time, let's
say greater than 8 hours--
so their fasting
blood sugar will
be right around 80
milligrams per deciliter,
give or take a little bit.
There's a range around
that, but I just
want to show you what would
happen to a normal person.
So at 80 milligrams
per deciliter,
their blood sugar
will kind of be--
should, hopefully, be
right around there.
And sometimes this
fasting blood sugar--
and maybe we're assuming
that this is in the morning.
So maybe this hour one
is 7:00 in the morning.
So they haven't
eaten for a while,
and that's why it's
fasting blood sugar.
This is also-- you'll
sometimes hear doctors,
I've heard my wife say
this word without knowing
what it meant-- they'll
sometimes say preprandial,
which is a very fancy word
which just means before a meal,
prandial is literally
before eating.
After the meal, you're
talking postprandial.
So it's a very fancy word for
a very simple idea, eating.
So let's say at hour two, this
individual eats breakfast.
So this is where the individual
is going to eat breakfast.
Now in a normal person, when
that person eats breakfast,
there'll be some carbohydrates
in that breakfast,
and it will be broken
down into glucose,
and that glucose will
enter the bloodstream.
And so their blood
glucose will go up.
It'll slowly go up.
And I was reading some studies.
They say it kind of spikes at
about 45 minutes into a meal.
So let's see.
45 minutes is over there.
So maybe it'll go
up to about there.
And in a normal individual,
the blood glucose really
shouldn't go up above 120
milligrams per deciliter.
And there's obviously
exceptions to all of these.
We're just kind of saying,
a normal breakfast,
a normal person.
They're not eating
a pint of honey.
They're not doing
something crazy.
So let's say 120 would
be right around there.
A normal person, someone
who does not have diabetes,
it would be unlikely that
it would go above that.
And then actually,
after about two hours,
they're getting pretty
close to normal.
They get back under 100
milligrams per deciliter.
And then you go
beyond two hours,
they just kind of get close,
back to their baseline,
to that 80 milligrams
per deciliter.
So once again, this is normal.
And of course, don't
freak out if you
were to take a blood
test one morning,
and you were at like 85
milligrams per deciliter.
You're still not
far off from normal.
So obviously, there's
some variation
from person to person.
Now, if someone has diabetes,
if either they have type 1,
they don't have enough
insulin to actually process
the glucose, or if they
have enough insulin,
but their body is
desensitized to it.
The insulin isn't being
processed properly
so they can't
process the glucose,
we've seen that the glucose
concentrations will go up.
And so, in general, if you
were to wake up one morning
after not having eaten
for more than eight hours,
and you were to prick
your finger with one
of those little glucose monitors
you can get at the drug store,
and in your finger,
the blood sugar levels,
if you were to find
them to be-- Let's say
you were to find them to be
at 140, that's 140 milligrams
per deciliter.
It's a good indication.
I mean, you shouldn't freak out.
You should do multiple
tests and make sure
that it wasn't a false
reading or any of that.
And you should
definitely see a doctor.
Once again, don't view this
as any type of medical advice.
That is not the purpose of this.
The purpose of this
is just to understand
a little bit of what's going on.
Don't change your lifestyle
based on anything I tell you.
All right.
But if you do experience
that, it looks
like, at least just from
that one data point,
that your body isn't
processing sugar properly.
Because you've had over eight
hours to process the sugar,
for insulin to go into
your bloodstream and allow
glucose to be taken up and get
back down to a normal level.
But it still hasn't gone there.
So if you were to test
a value like that,
you should be concerned.
In general, the threshold, and
I've seen multiple thresholds
here, are between 100
and-- I've seen high,
kind of mid-120s to 130
milligrams per deciliter.
So that's kind of-- let
me do it in this range.
If your fasting blood
sugar is above this line
right here-- remember,
the fasting blood sugar.
Not after you've eaten a meal.
Your preprandial,
before a meal--
if it is above that
threshold right over there,
then you should at least-- you
should definitely see a doctor
and make sure that they can
see if you have diabetes.
But this would be
cause for concern.
Another thing is
if after a meal,
it spikes well
beyond that, we're
talking if it gets beyond 180.
And once again, these
are all just thresholds
that doctors have come up with
and researchers have come up
with that say, hey, this
is a good indication
that somehow you are not
processing glucose properly.
So 180 is up here.
And I'm drawing it
as a squiggly line
because it's kind of a range.
It's not like if your blood
glucose is 124, you're safe.
And all of a sudden at
125, you have diabetes.
No.
They're not that
different than each other.
But they have to set
up some threshold just
to kind of have a
threshold, I guess.
So if your blood sugar,
after eating a meal,
were to spike up
to, let's say 200,
once again, that would
be cause for concern.
So in general, if
someone has diabetes,
because they're not processing
the glucose properly,
their blood glucose might
look something like this.
So maybe their
fasting blood glucose
is right around 125, 130.
It can move around.
Then they have a meal.
Then it might spike up.
Obviously, they can process
some of the glucose.
Otherwise, they would die.
But it's not being
processed properly.
So the glucose levels don't
go down to where they should.
And maybe some glucose gets
taken up from the blood.
Obviously they're
living, so their cells
are metabolizing something.
But it never gets down to
the normal 80 milligrams
per deciliter.
It might settle down, back
to something in the 120 range
or something like that, which
would be cause for concern.
And in general, if
you're someplace--
I've seen the threshold if
you're above 100 on a fasting
basis, that's cause for concern.
You should maybe
adjust your lifestyle.
And if you're above 120,
130 after meal, once again,
you should also be
slightly worried
that you might maybe
are prediabetic
or you have some risk
of developing diabetes.
So if someone has
blood sugar like this,
they're probably diabetic.
And if someone has
blood sugar like this,
they should be worried.
But once again, I
am not a doctor.
Don't take any of
this as advice.
This is really just our
attempt to understand
things a little bit better.